estos soldados ucranianos nos llevan a
sus posiciones al noreste de
aquí nos permiten filmar con una
condición no revelar su ubicación exacta
se ven cientos de metros de trincheras y
búnkers recién acabados
muy importante porque estamos a sólo 15
kilómetros de las afueras de kiev y el
aeropuerto de borisville no está lejos
por respeto
los rusos podrían utilizarlo para
desembarcar refuerzos y tomar la capital
la defensa se organiza para repeler las
columnas de tanques enemigos estos
soldados disponen de un armamento
temible para hacerlo
estas líneas de defensa pueden parecer
rudimentarias pero es ante todo gracias
a estos misiles antitanque que las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas han logrado
contener la avanzada rusa en este frente
situado al noreste de kiev un armamento
de punta suministrado por países
occidentales y que ha demostrado su
eficacia una y otra vez en las últimas
semanas
a los 59 años y lich ha vuelto al
servicio para defender a su país
me formé en la época soviética así que
me alisté en el ejército Para aprovechar
mis habilidades cuando crimea y el don
Bass fueron atacados sentí que tenía que
luchar Así que fui estoy en forma no
siento mi edad
aquí hay un regalo para los moscovitas
estaremos encantados de darles la
bienvenida con esto vamos los juguetes
Vladimir Putin pensaba en una Guerra
Relámpago que llevara sus tropas
directamente al corazón de la capital
pero las fuerzas ucranianas bloquean
hace varias semanas El Avance de los
blindados rusos por lo visto la batalla
de kiev apenas empieza